so first of all i've seen the first four
episodes of season three congratulations
fast moving
fans are gonna of course love it um i
want to start i think with the most
important question right up front and
max it's for you um true or not true
science invented a pill that had you
grow like two feet and i want to know
how what pill this is and how can i get
it
there's got to be something in the
chicago water because it was uncanny
like even like even the because i i went
two years uh in between season two and
three almost two years right
uh and um
yeah it was two years and uh and we
even the people who i saw every day were
kind of
amazed with my growth i saw my i
remember walking downstairs like a week
before we ship out to vancouver and um
and i walk downstairs and my mom goes
max
did you grow overnight and sure enough i
had grown overnight nearly an inch and
um
so there's got to be something in the
water and thank goodness we filmed it as
soon as possible because i was like five
eight or five nine when we filmed the
third season and i'm 60 tall now so
yeah i'm not going to say anything
except uh i hate you and
that's what i got um so jumping into
things for the three of you guys um
often when i speak to casts they talk
about um they like have a group chat
together you know like where they're
texting all the time so i'm curious did
you have that and who uh texts too much
well we definitely have we definitely
have like
let me let me preface this with
i was 11 when this show started uh the
only person that i feel like should have
known how to use technology was mina and
taylor and i was amazed that we still
had like 12 group chats running at the
same time because nobody knew how to use
technology and make one um i was also
amazed at the amount of emails that were
sent instead of text messages
because
i don't check my email i i sometimes
forget that i have an email um
so we definitely have many group chats
uh and i would say that parker texts
probably the most um because she'll send
like
articles about space
uh that she'll find really interesting
or she'll probably send like a carl
sagan like clip about space it just
feels like very parker thing could do
you guys agree
oh yeah
so one of the things about uh this is
obviously the third and final season of
the series and i'm curious for each of
you guys what was it like actually in
the last day of filming and how
emotional it might have been for you
guys and hypothetically what did you
borrow from set with the intention of
bringing it back
i feel like it was funny because we all
rapped at different times um we didn't
all rap on one day
so max and i wrapped last
and it was kind of like watching
everybody go home it was kind of like a
dragged out
version of a goodbye
um the last day
was really emotional and we all kind of
got together there was a big zoom call
and everybody was there and it was a big
moment
um
but it did feel like we had been
preparing for that from like two weeks
before just seeing like fewer and fewer
people come to work
uh
i i haven't borrowed anything that i
intend on returning i've maybe borrowed
a few things that i intend on keeping
um
but uh yeah
yeah the last day
well yeah because they we all wrapped at
different times i wrapped like the day
before
i mean
the day before christmas eve or
something
something crazy like that and
it was very very very emotional
and
you know season wraps i've never done
one before but the whole crew is there
and these are people that you've worked
with for
so many years and
i was leaving vancouver and going to new
york so
i knew i wasn't going to see
most of those people for a very long
time um
and yeah i don't know there's a lot of
reflection a lot of tears and
yeah it's kind of this big release in a
way
so you don't really know how it's gonna
feel but i cried a lot
yeah yeah um my final day was also
mina's final day uh
i and it was it's kind of surreal kind
of looking back on it um i don't it
definitely didn't hit me when when for
another like month or two
uh until i you know was going back and
looking through photos but um
no it was it was an emotional day for
sure but it was also kind of a
bittersweet day too because you know we
were coming to an end of a journey but
also
you know um lost in space what what
probably the most important part of it
for me was the people that i met so i
was really looking forward to doing
doing uh
other things down the road with with
these people because i know that they
weren't gonna live my life for sure and
um there's definitely some stuff that i
kept it's season one we have this
silicone dummy kind of thing of of of me
that they made it was like life-size at
the time um and
uh
we only were able to use it for season
one like after you know i would pumpkin
or run out of hours to work at the day
they would just throw it in the
background of a scene and look like i
was in there and um we only used it
season one
sat in storage for season two and then
they discovered it in season three and i
throw it in people's trailers or like on
their steps i have some videos of it
and um
and then like i got crafty with it like
i would pretend to be the dummy
sometimes so they think it's the dummy
and then i'd like jump out at them so i
got to keep that and i used it for
online school a few times like i would
sit in front of my camera
and then i would like go play the new
spider-man game or something
i'm gonna be completely honest with you
and um
time very well spent in online school
and then um
i also got to keep the tiny little robot
model that uh i that that i make and
that me and that me and penny make in
season uh in season one episode seven
episode seven and um i got to keep it
and the light still works and everything
but as soon as that battery dies it's
over because i have no clue how to
change it
um i think if you're one of your
teachers is watching your f's um but
anyway
it's fine i graduated sophomore year so
i'm in junior year now that i don't deal
with it
i um for all three of you guys um what
are you what are you allowed to actually
tease about season three what what do
you want to tell fans about it
everybody dies uh no um
no basically
what i can say
is that um
will robinson for the past two seasons
we've we've been building up that he's
growing that he's becoming a young adult
and then in season three we really
we really hammer that home knowing it's
the final season we wanted we wanted to
make sure that we did that that we
really completed this portion of his
life so um
you can definitely expect an older will
robinson uh and then you know of course
with age comes responsibility individual
responsibility and um
so with that comes
individual decisions and then
consequences and having to deal with
those consequences yourself
yeah and i think um as with the last two
seasons it always
kind of builds in scope too so because
we start the season or um separated from
the parents there's a lot that we have
to learn to do on our own without being
able to rely on the support system that
we've had before
so it is kind of
seeing
how the kids are able to face new
challenges um and then how the parents
are handling the separation as well
yeah i mean this season is all about
reconciliation coming back together and
being you know
lost and for lack of a better word and
um
it was a really loud back from that side
of my door
oh guys in here um but
yeah i think there's gonna be a lot of
mystery and a lot of adventure and it's
gonna feel really big and exciting and
um
also sad because it's you know coming to
a close but
but yeah hopefully they can
have some chill times ahead of all the
madness they've experienced the last
few years um yeah
on that note i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say i'm looking forward to seeing the
last four episodes and um thank you so
much for giving me your time and you
know wish you nothing but the best thank
you
you